what's the craziest uh
bmf party or event you guys i've heard
stories about these parties that are
legendary insane what's the craziest
thing your birthday
yeah me birthday party nothing nothing's
[ __ ] with it to this day
i met there was a magic city party where
i literally saw
regular women turn into strippers like
shot the hannah king
that party was crazy yeah yeah it's the
great used to have like animals
yeah yeah and hannah put that together
the invitation remember you you
opened it up and it talked to you it was
like like a diploma like it came wrapped
like
in a diploma you opened it up and then i
think it was blue da vinci like yeah
come to
hang with big meech in the jungle i was
like what happened
what was there it wasn't walking right
tigers are right here it was giraffes
yeah it was all types of [ __ ] yeah they
got giraffes there they had giraffes
she had everything yeah that was a
legendary time i mean just even
you know like and we're talking about
one of the
craziest but like just on a regular
night of visions on a tuesday or was it
thursday whatever the night or
both of them you know them [ __ ] would
literally come in and be like
50 100 deep and everyone would have a
bottle like yeah this is like early
it was just a different time like
nothing was like that error
you know yeah i remember one specific
time i was djing or off night
and i think um it was what it dude
pimping
i think it was uh either jeezy jeezy and
bumby
and one night i played it and it was
like every time you play that joint you
know put 100
on the table man i think i left for 3
500 i'm not even
lying oh i'm not lying i think yeah or
fact
every time it was like this every time i
ran it back they was just dropping it
like this and i was like oh [ __ ] this is
real
yeah the first time i ever saw any real
money was because of bmf
like so i had an a trip no no but even
before the la trip
um uh
i was doing gangster girls i think it's
still when it was like regular mixtape
and i asked blue da vinci like yo you
want to sponsor a tape like you know i
put a song on put your logo on and
everything
he was like how much i was like you know
like eight you know what i mean
something he was like hey
i got this no problem i'm thinking 800
dollars you know he literally takes me
to a crib and gives me eight grand
like i'd never seen that type of money
like
that [ __ ] i had that eight grand for
like i literally had the cash and i had
it in my closet maybe for about a year
you know i was still making okay money
but never where i had gotten
that eight grand chunk of money at one
at one time it was like
it blew me away wow yeah it was a shot
to those guys man shot the blue
shunt shout out to me shout out to t you
know i mean it was just a
it was a it was it was a special time in
atlanta i i and correct me if i'm wrong
y'all but isn't
isn't that the era where throwing money
in the air comes from yes
absolutely absolutely right comes from
absolutely from that era like and if it
didn't i'm gonna give it to him yeah
because i i've been in so many
like dj and strip clubs where it was
piles of money this high bro i've never
seen nothing like that him jd
nelly them they all it was different it
was different bro what which
was different what did people do in the
strip clubs before we made it rain like
i don't even remember like how did the
transaction go
yeah like it changed the whole culture
in the west coast we not you know
we come from a culture where it's like
we're not throwing nothing you know what
i'm saying
at all you know like it's it's amazing
couple dollars being thrown but what
they used to do like the briefing cases
and trash bags like come on that [ __ ]
was that [ __ ] was
true everything was already legendary
wow
that's crazy legendary